ça plume sensible lui a valu d'être
salué comme la relève des auteurs
dramatiques elle a fait ses classes avec
Christian Benedetti et Édouard bond et
elle porte haut les couleurs du théâtre
contemporain cette comédienne émettur en
scène présentera cette saison deux
spectacles à la ferme de Bel et ben Les
Misérables libre cours adaptés
tu viens ici
du roman Victor Hugo des Misérables sur
lesquels j'avais travaillé en fait en
maîtrise ce qui m'avait fasciné dans ce
roman c'était sa capacité à sortir de sa
forme première le romanesque ça
m'intéressait de partir de figures que
tout le monde connaît Fantine Jean
Valjean Cosette sans véritablement avoir
lu le roman comme des figures un peu
plastiques qui représentent notre
mémoire collective notre culture
nationale et j'avais envie de rendre ça
aux enfants
je suis partie dans mon travail du texte
véritable du coup mais après ce que je
leur propose sur scène ça n'a presque
plus rien à voir puisque c'est une
réécriture quasi totale de la pièce ça
se passe en une heure donc on est loin
d'une volonté d'exhaustivité on est
juste sur le parcours des enfants on
suit plus précisément celui de Cosette
qui est ensuite qui émaillé de la
rencontre avec éponyme Gavroche puis
Marius ce que Hugo appelle la misère au
XIXe siècle voilà tirer un petit fil à
partir de là pour l'amener tout
doucement à ce que nous aujourd'hui on
appelle la précarité
je n'étais pas seulement pauvre je
devenais misérable
vous savez
misérable
c'est quand on a pas l'argent et qu'on a
pas le temps
en une heure une traversée des
Misérables avec des repères très clairs
pour les gens puisqu'ils en ont une idée
préconçue si on le on le mélangeait à
notre sauce à l'heure à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui contemporaine et précaire
qu'est-ce que ça donne comment ces
personnes là
réagissent dans nos situations à l'heure
actuelle les choix de mise en scène mais
déjà c'est de dans la dramaturgie de se
concentrer sur les enfants donc ça leur
fait des
identifications faciles
c'est un spectacle qui est construit un
peu en deux parties ça s'ouvre sur Pôle
Emploi elle essaye de trouver du travail
la jambe Pôle Emploi lui demande si elle
a un CV elle a jamais fait ce genre de
choses puis le bébé se met à pleurer et
pollue complètement la conversation et
prend le devant de la scène et on entre
dans la fiction par Cosette bébé dans la
deuxième partie ensuite on passe à
l'adolescence de causette ou ça ça
m'intéressait de le de le tirer au bout
de tirer ce fil là pour les enfants pour
qu'ils voient un peu comment comment on
peut se construire quoi au niveau des
des costumes et des décors on est du
coup dans quelque chose d'assez
contemporain et ensuite quand on arrive
chez la Thénardier là on entre dans ce
qu'on attendrait on va dire du à la fois
du spectacle pour enfants et à la fois
du roman c'est à dire un décor plus
19eiste avec
tapis avec lampe en pied etc et petit à
petit la lumière monte monte pendant
toute la scène où elle découvre la
Thénardier pour qu'on s'aperçoit que
c'est juste un décor qui qui va partir
en lambeaux et de richesse il y en a pas
de bonté il y en a pas d'amour il y en a
pas un autre élément de décor qui est
très important
dans la pièce c'est le changement
le passage de vie à trépas de Fantine
puisque donc la mer meurt mais elle
reste présente pendant toute la pièce
elle devient donc confrontante qui est
présent sur un élément de décor que nous
on appelle le monument aux morts
mais voilà on crée les enfants avec des
enfants donc de Guyancourt qui vont
suivre un atelier hebdomadaire à partir
de janvier de deux heures avec
lesquelles on va travailler donc sur
cette pièce jeune public d'Édouard bond
on va travailler sous forme
d'improvisation et ensuite on va faire
un vrai spectacle l'idée c'est de
mobiliser les enfants sur un une pièce
qui nécessite leur présence
et qui est professionnel on a deux
acteurs professionnels qui jouent la mer
et l'homme en fait elle lui demande
d'aller incendier une maison et donc il
l'a promis il va le faire et une fois
qu'il a fait ça et un peu plus du tout
revenir auprès de sa mère qui lui a
demandé ça et s'en suit une errance dans
la ville dans une ville assez
fantomatique avec d'autres enfants qui
rencontrent et ils vont essayer comme ça
de recréer une nouvelle humanité après
cette cette dévastation une dévastation
de leur humanité d'avoir été contraint
comme ça par amour de faire quelque
chose qui est inacceptable et injuste
et des temps de retrouver Johanna Soudry
avec un tout nouveau sujet de la
rédaction et toi tu suis là tu vois je
sais pas vu
d'habitude
Idris Da Silva donne des cours de
hip-hop aujourd'hui c'est lui l'élève il
est venu découvrir le concept des
hip-hop Games
le groove le feeling et tout ça les
hip-hop Games ont été créées par Romuald
brisolier champion du monde de hip-hop
en 2009 cette année le concept
s'installe à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
dans le cadre des Pulsations Urbaines
une thématique chère à l'agglomération à
Magny-les-Hameaux Johanna Faya proposé
un stage d'initiation au hip-hop Games
concept durant tout un après-midi c'est
s'amuser et
ne surtout pas se juger et juste
s'écouter et ne pas avoir peur
d'accepter que si on est et de le danser
quoi en général il y a quatre groupes
qui sont composés de quatre personnes et
en fait ces quatre personnes elles vont
faire tour à tour des jeux les équipes
s'affrontent lors d'un show en plusieurs
épreuves improvisaient avec l'autre
jouer autour d'un objet les hip-hop
Games recherche une dimension théâtrale
dans la danse sur trois musiques avoir
trois gestuelles différentes trois
intentions différentes trois personnages
différents et ensuite bah quand la
musique switch pouvoir switch personnage
le hip-hop Games concept une performance
à mi-chemin entre battle et création
dernière date d'initiation samedi 10
novembre à Trappes avant le show de
hip-hop Games concept à Guyancourt le
samedi 17 novembre
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de vous rendre en famille au bébé nageur
lors on vous le y sera le 17 novembre en
concert à la ferme du Mane à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le collectif
hip-hop groove control investira quant à
lui la Meuse attrape le 17 novembre le
20 novembre Patrick Pineau mettra en
scène Lille à une pièce qui porte mal
son nom le suicidé au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le 20 novembre
toujours Antoine Hervé proposera après
la batterie une nouvelle leçon de jazz
mais au prisme cette fois et elle sera
consacrée à Duke Ellington autre date
qui déménage La Ruda et les hyènes
seront en concert pour une des dernières
fois pour la Ruda qui se sépare à la fin
de l'année le 24 novembre à la batterie
à Guyancourt des dates que vous pouvez
retrouver ainsi que l'ensemble de la
programmation culturelle des salles 50
images dans le kiosque sur Internet aux
adresses qui s'affichent et n'oubliez
pas que chaque mardi vous pouvez gagner
des places de spectacle sur le site du
kiosque
www.qiosque.ski.fr vous jouez pour
gagner des places pour la nuit du cinéma
aux accents hip-hop de l'estam inet